Hey Youtubers it's Charlie so the Flash and
Arrow just confirmed the dates that they're
coming back this fall it is pretty much the
exact same time they came back last year the
flash season two starts Tuesday, October 6
arrow season four starts that next day Wednesday,
October 7 both of them will have 23 episodes
the you like the first nine big on winter
break then come back in January since there
premiering at the same time I'm expecting
them to come back in January the same time
it's is like the third week in January which
would be January 19 for the flash this year
and the 20th for arrow legends of tomorrow
though and everyone still confused about when
that starts episode one will probably debut
the same week flashing arrow come back in
January they haven't said which night that's
going to air on yet but I'm expecting it to
air on a different night from flashing arrow
which would make it Monday Thursday or Friday
they're filming legends of tomorrow right
now so though the probably have some news
it, con though the privately some more information
about what's going on with that they just
hired their showrunner his name's Phil Klemmer
he was the show runner on the tomorrow people
you another Greg Berlanti show he worked on
Veronica Mars you worked on Chuck so he's
with a lot of these actors before and the
producers they did say this year flashing
arrow will tee up the plot of legends of tomorrow
so they might use the midseason finale of
both shows that the T that up or they can
use the episode eight flare a story the doing
the same thing they did last year where there
is like a shared villain between error on
the flash that starts on flash and moves to
arrow that's not the only crossover though
like all the shows all three shows will crossover
with each other is is that the flarrow crossover
involves most of the main cast jumping from
show to show the thing they did last year
with the midseason finales those it after
they do that flair episode each show had its
own independent story for the midseason finale
the flash is all about revealing Harrison
Wells is the reverse flash in the arrow episode
was all about killing all over the might do
the same thing or that they might make some
of legends a tomorrow stuff in there I'm slowly
starting to get ready for, comic con I'm not
expecting them to show off a lot of new footage
is because they don't start shooting flash
and they don't start shooting arrow till the
Monday after, con it's kind of a bummer but
Mark Guggenheim said that they're not to bring
in arrow season for trailer so I'm assuming
they're not to bring a flash season two trailer
do not to come empty-handed though, con this
year is huge for TV and for Warner Bros. in
general Marvel Sony and Paramount aren't taking
any of their film stuff so obviously Warner
Bros. definitely stepping up their Batman
versus Superman presence the the pressure
off the new trailer but Warner Bros. TV is
a huge deal like last year they did the big
super panel the pregnant do that again they
have Supergirl to promote this is really like
DC's year so there's going to be a whole bunch
of stuff do not to come empty-handed if anything
they might bring the blooper reels from flashing
arrow there was actually this weird thing
somebody some random person posted the arrow
season three blooper reel to YouTube this
morning it's since been taken down it's been
torpedoed by Warner Bros. lawyers but I have
no idea how they get their hands on it because
the DVD is an out till September what's probably
can happen a, con is the just each of the
shows will just talk about some the new characters
they have coming in some of the new plot lines
we already know about like the Patty Spivot
type character that the flash is casting they
might have some more characters the ready
to announce we know about mere master we know
about Dr. alchemy I'm sure everybody's going
to be asking Daniel Panabaker in the producers
about killer frost stuff so the be tons a
flash stuff to talk about as for arrow we
know all about Damien Darhk they just announced
a new African-American character that supposed
to be like a tech type person that will interact
a lot with Felicity Marc Guggenheim did say
that they were going to follow-up on the Felicity
CEO thing in a big way you member at the end
of season four she signed the papers that
that essentially gave her control of palmar
tech she wrote off with all over into the
sunset so it seem like they drop that storyline
but Marc Guggenheim's like nope that's going
to be a big deal in season four I think the
biggest question I'm expecting people that
Stephen Amell though is will he be green arrow
by the end of the season because he said the
arrow identity is completely dead he's not
to be calling himself the arrow anymore so
even if they don't of trails the show off
I mean is this still going to be like a ton
of stuff and yes they are doing like the big
super TV panel where they have like all the
DC TV shows together at the same time but
arrow in the flash will do their separate,
con panels to they haven't announced to their
bringing it'll probably be most the main cast
or any of the actors that are busy filming
other stuff at the moment John Barrowman said
he literally just signed his arrow season
for contract I guess he has to sign a new
contract once a year but it just confirms
will be seeing a lot of Merlyn Ra's al Ghul, I think that was part of my predictions
for season four how ridiculous would it have
been if he had not re-signed and come back
for season four like they would to just drop
that storyline I haven't really done any big,
con preview videos yet but what's can happen
is is when we get a little bit closer and
then announce the final schedule I'll say
which panels I'll be recording I mean obviously
I'll do like the flash and arrow but there
will be videos on top of those panel videos
like if they release trailers or anything
like that. I know I've been doing the weekly
Marvel DC giveaway but when we actually do
get to that week of comic con, I'll do
special merch giveaways because they'll have tons of
cool comic con toys what I'm gonna  try and do
is Wednesday night on preview night him and
try and buy like as much stuff as possible
that's when I blow my money. My big question
for you guys you given all the stuff they've
announced about legends of tomorrow arrow in
the flash what are you most excited about
inside the Arrow verse for this next year the
two words on the tip of my tongue right now
are Vandal Savage I'm so excited to see how
they weave legends a tomorrow and these are
the two shows it's meant to be a show all
by itself like a will have its own storyline
but they're using it is like this platform
to weave this larger comic book universe if
you haven't read convergence or you haven't
been reading secret wars on the on the Marvel
side of things they have like this big comic
book event once a year and that all these
lesser titles that we then with that that's
what they're doing with the Aero verse right
now so the secret wars of the Arrow verse is
legends of tomorrow convergence would probably
be a better comparison but I'm a bigger fan
of secret wars right now that I am of convergence
originally had intended to do a video on killer
frosts I was going to be like by next flash
video but I wanted to talk about the premier
just just because they literally just announced
that this morning so my next flash video will
be killer frosts be sure to subscribe to get
it and I had to do to enter like the DC Marvel
giveaways is just be subscriber and leave
a comment whenever I post Marvel and DC videos
that it's really simple we have to mention
Arkham Knight too though I just got my PS
for Arkham bundles so I'll probably be doing
gameplay videos in the next couple days the
PC version is supposed to suck something fierce
so I would advise going with the console version
what I'll do with those videos is all put
the first one on this channel just so I know
everybody finds it and then I'll post all
the other gameplay videos on my Charlie Streams
bonus channel there's a link for that in description
maybe some streaming this weekend on my twitch
channel too, also a link for that in the description
so there's like a whole bunch of stuff happening
right now hopefully guys are having panic
attacks from all the excitement but in case
you didn't see the news yesterday new Spider-Man
announced you can click here for my video
my reaction to that and you can click here
to learn all about the multi-verse on the
flash season 2, thank you so much for watching,
everybody let's High Five and I'll see you
guys tonight!